а мне очень интересно наверное нашим
зрителям тока как вы подходите к выбору
о проекта как вы инвестируете деньги как
вообще в целом готовы принести кому-то
человеку или проектом 5 миллионов
долларов на что вы ориентируетесь
костанае цены но если мы будем говорить
об айти проектах отделов лучше в
зависимости от подход инвестирует или не
инвестирует зависит от многих факторов
один из факторов это первую очередь
портфель потому что это не просто многие
очень упрощенно подходит к понятию
инвестор самом деле я очень много без не
говори что нельзя путать со стула
инвесторы и бизнесмен это два разных
стула и
занятия им естественный это
профессиональная работа восьмичасовая
где ты должен профессионал и где это
эмиссионной процесс это тоже процесс ему
нужно алгоритмизировать там прописаны
скажи шаги там нету такого
художественного такого свободного
творчества когда что-то мне нравится и
произнести вот такого абсолютно нет
настоящей эффективный именно портфель
это достаточно рутинная скучная работа и
изначально когда ты делаешь дизайн
портфеля ты прописываешь инвестиционную
декларацию и в это имитационной
декларации ты прописываешь куда я
инвестирую почему в какие отрасли во что
инвестировать что никогда не буду
инвестирует как я оцениваю метрики и
успешности неуспешности по каким
метрикам я буду судить и так далее так
далее и поэтому у каждого им сумма part
виды есть в своей эволюционно декларации
так вот если мы будем говорить про идти
портфель и в частности осады винчи фон
то там прежде всего я смотрю на рынок
это прежде всего то что на что я смотрю
потому что смотрите я рынке делю на три
большие категории зависимости от глубины
и от размера первые the ocean и второй
это моря 3 от озера
почему не так делю потому что есть такое
правило прилив поднимает все лодки
независимо от эффективности ты даже на
дырявые лодке во время прилива
поднимаешься поэтому
я
откуда это
принял для себя дело в том что и когда
ты работаешь на больших рынках это океан
и
приливы их предсказать легче и более
того когда происходит прилив ты
зарабатываешь банка даже если ты не
угадал сладкой даже если не угадал фотки
поэтому я чудный размер рынка это
количество населения а глубина это
количество денег вот на руках у
населения так вот например сша это океан
если мы возьмем китай от океан а если мы
возьмем индию это больше море большое
ногами на маленькая казахстан по озеру и
казахстана то выше у озера поэтому если
исходить из этой молод и что получается
при ли вы угадать легче есть и ты угадал
то прилив поднимает все лодки
но они случаются только в океанах на
море ты можешь угадать только шторм
большую волну тоже хорошо заработать но
волну года сложнее чем прилив и волна
понимает не все лодки а
если брать озеру это на озере ряд
угадать вообще практически невозможно и
даже если ты угадал ты заработаешь не
так много даст фактически это анти
авантюрный метод то есть доля какого-то
авантюризма или какой-то мысли вот пост
попробовал вдруг стрельнет месяца
вопрос чем
авантюризм на самом деле в этом ничего
хорошего нет вам быть людьми когда это
просто полагание на случай моем случае я
всегда считаю что я должен сделать свою
домашнюю работу прежде чем просить у
аллаха везение и помощи я должен
выполнить на 99 свою часть работы так
вот первый критерий которые я смотрю это
размер рынка и на каком рынке компания
собирается передавать либо уже оперирует
второй момент я смотрю на команду потому
что если у вас хороший капитан лодки то
даже в отсутствие приливы при лево или
во время отлива он все равно не даст
утонуть свои лодки потому что
от умений капитана зависит так вот кому
тебя вести во время отлива как водка
будет ввести на море бойлеры и так далее
поэтому на втором месте это капитан и
его команда 3 я смотрю на качество самой
лодки то есть какую боль это лодка
решать как у больно эта компания решает
4 я смотрю как они решают эту боль и 5 я
смотрю смогу ли я до финансирует эту
компанию или хватит ли у меня дыхалки
например компании приходит ко мне и
просит 500000 долларов егор хорошо
какой-то рамок анекдот такой-то такой-то
рам привлечение министерстве егорова
хорошо до выхода на точку безубыточности
вам сколько еще нужно по времени они
году два года хорошо какой в сборной
уровень ожиданий мой ник вид на простую
100 тысяч долларов в месяц я прикидывал
значит 2 миллиона 400 тысяч долларов она
наверняка они еще занижают или оптимист
и поэтому минимум 3 3 равные потребуется
чтобы выйти на точку безубыточности
сейчас они у меня просят 500 тысяч евро
где вы возьмете остальные они говорят
следующем раунде мы будем еще привлекать
а я думаю если кризис произойдет
наверняка у них не будет следующего
воронова раунда наверняка у них не будет
нового инвестора соответственно чтобы
спасти 500 своих 500000 долларов мне
придется еще до инвестировать три три с
половиной
готов ли я пойти на это или нет готов ли
в эту компанию оставались только деньги
или нет вот это пятый
фактор который я оцениваю при
инвестировании в эти компании но мне
очень повезло пункта наверное вы ведь
эту информацию оставляете для платных
курсов где вы объясняете могут
предпринимать для мы собственные методы
это знаешь вы на самом деле в платных
курсах я даю чуть чуть другой срезе
информации другие вещи более конкретно
более глубокие
здесь с особо ничего секретного нет я
наоборот везде декларирую для чего для
того чтобы ко мне пристали не сырые
проекты чтобы изначально люди понимали и
это на самом деле является одним из
элементов управления ожидания люди
увидев мою такой интервью они уже
понимает вошло я буду инвестировать во
что не буду соответственно вот я в день
получаю от десяти до двенадцати бизнес
планов и проектов в день
соответственно меня не будет присылать
кучу мусора
90 95 просто так как правило я открыл
сразу отказываю